[Music]
this is the tale of two ancient cities
and the trees that determined their
destinies in 3000 bc uruk was more
densely populated than modern-day new
york city this crowded capital had to
continually expand their irrigation
system to feed its growing population
2,500 years later in Sri Lanka the city
of anuradhapura had a similar problem
they were also growing constantly and
like Brook their city relied heavily on
an elaborate irrigation system as Luke
grew its farmers began chopping down
trees to make space for more crops in
anuradhapura however trees were sacred
their city housed an offshoot of the
Bodhi tree under which buddha himself
was said to have attained enlightenment
religious reverence slowed farmers axes
and even led the city to plant
additional trees in urban parks
initially were rooks expansion worked
well but without trees to filter their
water supply works irrigation system
became contaminated evaporating water
left mineral deposits which rendered the
soil too salty for agriculture
conversely a nirodha parez irrigation
system was designed to work in concert
with the surrounding forests their city
eventually grew to more than twice
Brookes population and today
anuradhapura still cares for a tree
planted over 2,000 years ago we may
think of nature as being unconnected to
our urban spaces but trees have always
been an essential part of successful
cities trees act like a natural sponge
absorbing stormwater runoff before
releasing it back into the atmosphere
the webs of their roots protect against
mudslides while allowing soil to retain
water and filter out toxins roots help
prevent floods while reducing the need
for storm drains and water treatment
plants their porous leaves purify the
air by trapping carbon
and other pollutants making them
essential in the fight against climate
change humanity has been uncovering
these arboreal benefits for centuries
but trees aren't just crucial to the
health of a city's infrastructure they
play a vital role in the health of its
citizens as well in the 1870s Manhattan
had a few trees outside the islands
parks without trees to provide shade
buildings absorbed up to nine times more
solar radiation during deadly summer
heat waves combined with the periods
poor sanitation standards the oppressive
heat made the city a breeding ground for
bacteria like cholera in modern-day Hong
Kong tall skyscrapers and
underground infrastructure make it
difficult for trees to grow this
contributes to the city's dangerously
poor air quality which can cause
bronchitis and diminished lung function
trees affect our mental health as well
research indicates that the presence of
green foliage increases attention spans
and decreases stress levels it's even
been shown that hospital patients with
views of brick walls recover more slowly
than those with views of trees
fortunately many cities are full of
views like this and that's no accident
as early as the 18th century city
planners began to embrace the importance
of urban trees in 1733 Colonel James
Oglethorpe planned the city of Savannah
Georgia to ensure that no neighborhood
was more than a two minute walk from a
park after World War two Copenhagen
directed all new development along five
arteries of each sandwiched between a
park this layout increased the city's
resilience to pollution and natural
disasters and urban trees don't just
benefit people
Portland's Forest Park preserves the
region's natural biodiversity making the
city home to various local plants 112
bird species and 62 species of mammals
no city is more committed to trees than
Singapore since 1967 Singapore's
government has planted over 1.2 million
trees
including those within 50 meter tall
vertical gardens called super trees
these structures sustain themselves and
nearby conservatories with solar energy
and collected rainwater trees and
vegetation currently cover over 50
percent of Singapore's landmass reducing
the need for air conditioning and
encouraging low pollution transportation
by 2050 it's estimated that over 65
percent of the world will be living in
cities city planners can lay an
eco-friendly foundation but it's up to
the people who live in these urban
forests to make them homes for more than
humans the time to get involved with the
climate movement is now don't know where
to start we've partnered with the UN to
create a 30 day challenge designed to
teach you everything you need to know to
become a part of the solution start the
challenge with a friend or family member
today